>>> WOULD RUSSIA CUT ITS LOSSES
AND PULL OUT?
SHARING A NUMBER OF SIMILARITIES
FROM ANOTHER TIME WITH ITS
ATTACK ON UKRAINE NOT JUST HOW
THE WAR BEGAN OR SUPPORT ROLE
PLAYED BY THE UNITED STATES, BUT
ALSO HOW BECAUSE OF HOW MANY
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS HAVE DIED SO
FAR.
JOINING ME NOW HERE IN
WASHINGTON CNN NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST PETER BERGEN.
YOU STUDIED BOTH OF THESE
CONFLICTS EXTENSIVELY AND WROTE
AN OP-ED ON CNN.COM.
THERE IT IS NOW.
NUMBER THAT PUTS VLADIMIR PUTIN
AT RISK.
TALK ABOUT START OF THE WAR,
START OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION IN
AFGHANISTAN.
SIMILARITIES.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> THE BIG -- FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN
THE BIG SIMILARITY IS 15,000
RUSSIAN TROOPS MAY HAVE DIED
ACCORDING TO ESTIMATES FROM NATO
OFFICIALS TO CNN.
THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS DURING THE
1980 WAR AGAINST THE SOVIETS IS
15,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS DEAD.
SO IN NINE YEARS OF WAR DURING
'80s, 15,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
DIED.
IN ONE MONTH, 15,000 RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS DIED.
VLADIMIR PUTIN UNDERSTAND THE
BERLIN WAR FELL WHEN PULLED OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN.
A YOUNG KGB OFFICER.
HE MUST BE KEENLY AWARE THAT
THINGS CAN CHANGE NOT IN HIS
FAVOR IF ENOUGH BODY BAGS START
GOING HOME.
FURTHER BACK IN RUSSIAN HISTORY.
ROMANOVS LOST WORLD WAR ONE AND
THEN EXECUTED.
YOU FAIL IN WARS, COULD BE A BIG
PROBLEM FOR YOU YOURSELF.
>> RIGHT.
THEY DON'T TYPICALLY STICK
AROUND WHEN THEY'VE SUFFERED A
LOSS LIKER THAT EXPERIENCING NOW
AND UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING BACK
NOT EXACTLY THE WAY THE AFGHANS
DID DURING THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN, BUT THEY ARE
FIGHTING BACK IN LESS, I GUESS,
YOU KNOW, CATASTROPHIC TERMS,
USING MOLOTOV COCKTAILS, MANY
DEMONSTRATIONS AND SO ON, BUT
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE, THEY'RE
MAKING IT CLEAR THEY'RE NOT GROG
TO BE SUPPRESSED BY PUTIN,
RAILROAD GOING TO MOUNT
RESISTANCE.
AND IN MANY WAYS IT DOES REMIND
YOU OF HOW THINGS WENT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> YEAH.
BIG DIFFERENCE, JIM, THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE BETTER OFF THAN
THE AFGHANS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANTI-AIRCRAFT
UNTIL 1996.
HERE THEY HAVE THEM ALREADY.
ANTI-TANK WEAPONS.
RESULTS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
THE RUSSIAN KIND OF FAILURE IN
UKRAINE IS HAPPENING RATHER
DRAMATICALLY.
IF, INDEED THEY FAIL.
IT'S AN OPEN QUESTION.
CLEARLY NOT WINNING AND MAY BE
LOSING.
IN AFGHANISTAN UNTIL '86,
AFGHANS PUT UP A BIG FIGHT BUT
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT WEAPONS.
UKRAINIANS HAVE THE RIGHT
WEAPONS AND GET THEIR HANDS ON
THE S-300 WEAPONS, ANTI-AIRCRAFT
WEAPONS THEY KNOW HOW TO USE.
PRESSURE TO GET THOSE WEAPONS
INTO THE THEATER.
AND THAT WILL BE EVEN MORE A
GAME-CHANGER, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THEY CAN BRING DOWN BALLISTIC
MISSILES AND BRING DOWN HIGH
ALTITUDE AIRCRAFT WITH THESE
S-300s, STINGERS CANNOT.
>> RIGHT.
AND I GUESS YOU WRITE THERE'S A
CHANCE PUTIN COULD FEEL SO
CORNERED IN UKRAINE HE COULD USE
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
>> YES.
>> EVEN USE HIS NUCLEAR ARSENAL.
GOD FORBID THAT HAPPENS.
BUT WHAT IS THE AFGHAN
EXPERIENCE TELLING US ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT PUTIN WOULD GO
DOWN THAT ROAD IN UKRAINE THEN?
>> CERTAINLY THE AFGHAN
EXPERIENCE, SOVIETS KILLED 1
MILLION AFGHANS.
MINIMAL NUMBER.
AS MANY AS 2 MILLION.
MADE A THIRD OF THE POPULATION
HOMELESS.
THESE KINDS OF RUSSIAN TACTICS
SAW IT IN GROZNY, ALEPPO, THESE
ARE NOT NEW TACTICS.
>> ASK YOU ABOUT THE TALIBAN IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW.
TALIBAN POSTPONING RETURN TO
SCHOOL FOR GIRLS ABOVE THE SIXTH
GRADE.
U.S. REPRESENTATIVE FOR
AFGHANISTAN SAYS THAT CAUGHT THE
U.S. BY SURPRISE.
PERHAPS SHOULD NOT HAVE COME AS
A SURPRISE.
HELP VIEWERS UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T TOUCHED BASE
WITH YOU ON THIS IN SOME TIME.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, I FIND IT
DEEPLY UNSURPRISING.
SEVEN MONTHS AFTER THEY TOOK
POWER, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
PREVENTING GIRLS WHO ARE ABOVE
AGE 13 TO GO TO SCHOOL.
PUT THAT IN THE "UNSURPRISING
FILE."
NOT IN THE "DEEPLY SURPRISED
E"FILE.
PART OF THEIR PROJECT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
EXCLUDE WOMEN FROM THE WORKPLACE
AND EXCLUDE GIRLS FROM
EDUCATION.
THEY SAID THEY'D DESIGN A NEW
UNIFORM.
THE PROBLEM.
COME ON.
DOESN'T TAKE YOU SEVEN MONTHS TO
DESIGN A NEW UNIFORM.
IT'S AN EXCUSE UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T THINK SURPRISING AND KIND
OF PART OF THE PROJECT NOW.
THEY DIDN'T REFORM, JUST WINDOW
DRESSING WHEN THEY SAID WE'RE
DIFFERENT, AND THIS SHOWS THEY
HAVEN'T CHANGED.
>> YEAH.